these Syrian school children enjoy a
rare opportunity they get to have
english lessons in a school for refugees
on the edge of istanbul among them is
nine-year-old juma from Aleppo his
father was killed in the Syrian war juma
arrived in Istanbul late last year with
his mother and five siblings refugees
operate the school themselves but many
of those most in need can't attend
mungkin hueco few survive masala there
are many reasons students don't come for
some the school is too far and the
family doesn't have money for a bus for
others the father is unemployed and the
children have to work so the family can
survive and many more children have been
out of school for so long now that they
just don't keep up my sheet hath you my
you see juma lives just a short distance
from the school people donated his
clothing and school books he and his
siblings haven't received support from
the Turkish authorities nonetheless some
of his Turkish neighbors are unhappy
about the situation these refugees are
an enormous burden for our country
financially and mentally and all the
other countries have left us to deal
with it all alone eh by dashiell you
Juma's mother doesn't want to be filmed
every month she pays 100 80 euros to
rent this damp apartment with no warm
water the only place Juma can do his
homework is on the balcony but he
doesn't want to complain almost without
butter on mother sue actually I'm doing
quite well I can go to school and other
kids can't do that but of course I want
to return home to Syria soon nearly half
of the estimated two million Syrian
refugees in Turkey are minors but only a
small number of them live in the refugee
camps along the border most of the
families are scraping by in turkey's
larger cities they do have the right to
access free health care they can also
apply for a work permit as of recently
but this Syrian man who's now collecting
trash says it's not as easy as it
sounds tears are 11 professional mom
electives are but it's very difficult to
find proper work doing so requires
official documents that can take months
to get that's why a lot of us are trying
to survive on the jobs like these but
small children are often hit hardest by
having fled from home they need access
to schools already Syria is facing the
prospect of a lost generation